hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen leute zu einem neuen video
und meine softbox ist am arsch also
wundert euch nicht wenn die flackert
oder hatten sie getötet packe ich halte
diese schalten kamen dann luca wir
befinden uns hier in einem neuen video
und zwei spielen wie heute das hanauer
geht man in hannover geht es darum muss
ich das eigentlich immer jeden tag
erklären wir dem hanauer game geht es
darum dass wir zwei sachen zur auswahl
haben auf der linken seite eine sache
und auf der rechten seite eine sache und
wir müssen sagen ob die linke sache bei
der uns angegeben wurde wie oft sie
monatlich gegoogelt wird öfter gegoogelt
wird die rechte sache hat es verstanden
wird subway öfter gegoogelt als louis
vitton ich würde sagen nein also kings 6
millionen man muss sich dabei immer halt
überlegen subway ist einerseits zwar der
zehn staaten andererseits allerdings
auch steht ja auch in einer gewissen
form für so underground bahnen und sowas
deswegen würde ich sagen louis vitton
ist louis vitton 4 millionen alter wir
steigen auf jeden fall richtig krass
einkehr auf jeden fall weniger
ich weiß nicht mehr wer diese frau ist
worauf angry men auf jeden fall auch
weniger als ich weiß auch was wolfgang
rihm allen sind zwölf wütende leute
popeye denke ich hat mehr als 12 mrd
mich 1,8 millionen
dieser verfügte scheiß softbox ohne spaß
ich hab die seit vier jahren oder 5 da
fast echt gut gehalten kollege samsung
hat auf jeden fall mehr als popeye und
hat nämlich elf millionen samsung hat
elf millionen im monat das ist so viel
hatten wir noch nie glaube ich dass ich
schon eine menge
ich wünschte ich hätte mal so viele
abonnenten apple watch hat weniger als
samsung nämlich 3,3 millionen dann haben
wir roger federer hat auch weniger als
apple watch nämlich 12
das ist klasse folge die letzten mal
hatte ich so sachen wie ja die werden so
monatlich 800 mal gegoogelt jetzt habe
ich so 11 millionen
wo soll das noch hinführen sowie asis
hat glaube ich weniger als roger federer
nämlich genau gleich viel alter okay die
golden gate bridge denke ich okay sie
hat weniger michael schumacher hat
glaube ich mehr würde ich sagen nämlich
12 millionen obwohl er nicht mal
wirklich fährt sehen egal hat glaube ich
weniger als michael schumacher nämlich
306 nach 368.000 triathlon hat
mehr als 300 6 und 8 nein ich hatte
liebeskummer
dazu kommen die top ten percent range
und vanessa 11 11 fragen hintereinander
richtig beantwortet wie oft sachen
monatlich gegoogelt werden das hatte ich
noch niemand besser also mein bestes war
12 aber komm ich immer diese scheiss 12
die usual suspects habe ich keine ahnung
wer das ist wird aber weniger auf
googles als wild places hat mir
letztmals schon was das ist out boy
denke ich mehr als die user zur spex
kenne ich auch nicht aber 301 1000 dpi
auf jeden fall mehr als ob das verging
wort die pille also als ob das nicht
mehr google wird traurig ist so was was
ist los mit der welt ich war schon die
ganze zeit auf so ein müsli korn rom was
ich noch im mund hat kennt ihr das rugby
world cup gegen the big lebowski ich
glaubte big lebowski wird mehr google
nämlich 246.000 mal als jedes haben wie
caitlin caitlin gianna wird glaube ich
auch mehrere google weil es irgendwie
gender mit namen sind ja alle sehen
diese prominente leute ich kenne mich
damit nicht aus die wie wonder könnte
gleich viel haben ich sag mal weniger
nämlich 550.000 dann haben wir hier
venus williams hat auf jeden fall mehr
die tennisspieler okay juli dieses
offshore i was ich hab mal das mikro
hingerichtet vielleicht heute dass die
größe die ganze zeit falls dir tipps
habt consulting softbox problems in hot
fix ist die kommission aber reden und
max problem firma softbox wir versuchen
das einfach mal alle mit der softbox zu
ignorieren und konzentrieren uns auf das
spiel und zwar bei sat 1 daily hat auf
jeden fall mehr als 9 und 1 1800 23.000
dann fleetwood mac auf jeden fall
weniger nämlich nur 368.000 dann haben
wir glastonbury festival auch weniger
nämlich nur 60.000 dann haben wir als
nächstes charlie hebdo hat auf jeden
fall mehr als 60.000 mit 450.000 laser
herr revival hatten wir schon mal ich
glaube das hat aber weniger nämlich
genau 246.000 lady gaga auf jeden fall
mehr die geht in die millionen 33
millionen terrorist
ich klicke einfach weniger an und zwar
260.000 ok krass ich dachte es wird echt
öfter gegoogelt werden das iphone 6 es
hat auf jeden fall mehr nämlich 748
millionen das ist richtig viel chichi
grad weniger als 7,5 millionen ähnlich
27 millionen dann haben wir wiki diese
scheiß softbox wikileaks würde ich sagen
weniger als 27 millionen nämlich 450.000
dann haben wir wm definitiv öfter als
wikileaks nämlich das doppelte und
spongebob scorpions auf jeden fall auch
öfter nein schon wieder elf
es geht nicht ich komme nicht zurück in
zwölf deer hunter hat mehr als ps kommt
es soll nicht sein 0 letzte terrible
score fedex hat mehr als 12 millionen
monatlich nämlich sechs millionen die
nächste sache die wir brauchen ist
namibia das hat weniger als sechs
minuten 301 1000 collins hat mehr als
300 1 1000 mg 673.000 dann kommen wir
praktisch ist zum film machen wir lauer
und black tisch ist er glaube ich dieser
wahl
der hat da irgend ne praktisch ist der
film über anwahl der pflegerin getötet
hat oder so frisbee blablabla auf jeden
fall denke ich mir okay das war ganz
knapp den wie 40.000 mehr dass angelina
jolie geht auch in die millionen nämlich
vier millionen dann haben wir hier pop
auf jeden fall weniger hat mir auch
vorhin schon hat 18 millionen bei
rolling stones haben mehr als pop wisst
ihr ich mag diese seite ich mag diese
seite aber ein paar sachen für mich
einfach keinen sinn ich will einfach
gern mal ein fakt haben ob das alles
stimmt was die da von sich verzapfen und
wenn euch das video gefallen anlasten
leid da ich der haube kopf gegen die
wand bisher wehtut